ala welcome back to St Louis welcome
back to gr chour last year you had such
a great success really hard to imagine
how you can play even better but in are
you ready to repeat it yeah it's
impossible to play better but um maybe
it's impossible to Reit also but I will
try my best and we'll see I have good
memories here so yeah speaking about the
memories I mean when you landed here in
St Louis when you came around let's say
what did you feel how was it you know
yeah it's there is some
smell that is like good smell and I'm
very happy it's always like everything
is very comfortable the organizer and
they do everything for the players so
I'm really happy here and I hope it
continues all a lot more years and it
would be amazing um I mean you are
coming definitely from Grand Swiss I
mean just finished one week ago uh how
can you assess your participation there
your results um what can you say yeah
definitely it was disappointing and I
lost 15 ratings but uh yeah I have the
candidate spot I'm the favorite still
and here if I play decent I will clutch
it but we'll
see a lot of players Wesley has biggest
chance to catch me and it will be a very
close fight but um I I didn't play good
there but I hope I it was the experience
I learned and I could improve my play
here but yeah I mean I mean speaking
about this candidate spot um do you
regret for now for example that you
didn't take take part in Baku World Cup
let's say where you had another chance
opportunity to try to qualify because
now it's it's not really easy right to
qualify yeah um I mean I don't if I
really scared 100% about candidates I
would have played bku but it's something
that now I have chance I will try to use
it but if I don't make it it's not the
biggest deal for me I really want
because it's the candidat also is very
difficult tournament just one player out
of eight very good player goes up so in
general I want to improve my chest and
um I don't really think so much about
the cand spot but now that I have the
last tournament and the last chance it's
it's stupid to not care so but in
general I'm it would be good if I get
the spot but I will not try everything
right like that's very interesting what
you say because I mean I thought that
this is the main goal for for the player
like you I mean who is really on the top
and who can fight for the world
championship title to be in the
candidates tournament so let's say what
what actually happen to your motivation
let's say is it the fact that Magnus is
not playing is it the fact that you have
some other things to do in your life
like I mean just I'm trying to
understand it better um I it's just
beside Baku I played everywhere I played
Norway chess I played Romania I played
Zagreb but um I I mean Magnus dropped
also it means that there are things you
can play around not only world
championship and I like for instance
I'll prefer to have number one rating
spot also like it's uh there are many
goals you can achieve in chess it's not
like just or winning Grand chest to is
also a big thing so um candidates is
also one pass but you can choose other
pass wow that's exactly let's say you
have different goals in Chess World yeah
yeah wow that's really interesting do do
you have um like is it more important
for you for example to replace Magnus on
the top yeah yeah of course the rating I
think is also very important because if
for Magnus is the best player in the
world he's not world champion so it
means rating is also very important and
um ranking number one is good thing so I
also would like to achieve that but it's
a difficult task CU he's very at top now
let's say can you imagine yourself
participating in Grant tour in 10 years
let's say what do you think your life
will be in 10 years I definitely see
myself playing chess but um if
grandchester exists it's very good news
and I will if they invite me I will
participate but um yeah I see myself
playing chess I hope I achieve my
goals and um we'll see but I definitely
see myself playing ch that's great uh
thank you so much ala and all the best
for you in the tournaments thank
[Music]
you